for all the ceos and founders who are
listening on april 1st we will start
accepting applications for the 2023
class of the sea transformation program
the 11 month intensive program will
start in january and it includes a
combination of face-to-face teaching
networking and virtual learning
you'll have the opportunity to
participate in a cohort of 60 other
like-minded entrepreneurs from across
your region
founders and ceos of companies based in
sub-saharan africa in south asia with
annual revenue of at least three hundred
thousand dollars are eligible to apply
if you or a company you know may be
interested please visit stanford seed
dot co forward slash apply to learn more
[Music]
there's a japanese saying that sometimes
you have to jump through a window
not knowing what's outside
and the knowledge
of exactly what the problems are is
itself a constraint
every entrepreneur has to wrestle with
the unknown the most successful ones
develop a skill set to help them deal
with the things that they can't predict
therefore i think that if i had known
too much
about banking
i may not have done it but in that sense
i wasn't a professional banker
i was just an mba who just had that
certain overconfidence that mbas have
that any problem can be analyzed
can be assessed as a problem of
management
a strategy
can emanate from it and you should be
able to execute
[Music]
i'm darius teeter and welcome to season
two of grit and growth from stanford
seed the show where africa and india's
intrepid entrepreneurs share their
trials and triumphs with insights from
stanford faculty and global experts on
how to tackle challenges and grow your
business
[Music]
you'd be hard-pressed to find a more
accomplished person than our guest today
esteemed businessman hakeem bella osagie
this show isn't long enough to list
hakim's many many accomplishments but he
has been a driving force in the nigerian
economy for the last three decades
across such disparate sectors as energy
finance and telecoms
he's a business leader a philanthropist
and an educator
he's on the council of foreign relations
the international advisory council at
the brookings institute and he's a
lecturer at harvard business school
although we won't hold that one against
him
he's also the new chair of stanford
seeds board of directors
hakeem has a unique understanding of the
african entrepreneurial ecosystem and
the challenges it faces i sat down with
akeem to hear about his perspectives on
the nigerian economy
and the rapid growth of fintech startups
his experience taking over a state-run
bank in the late 90s and his vision for
the modern business leader
here's hakeem humble and understated as
always
my name is hakim balosage i am from
nigeria
i went to university in england and in
the united states
that would be oxford
cambridge and harvard in case you were
wondering
i then went back to nigeria and worked
in the government of nigeria for many
years in the president's office
and then decided after maybe a decade
that i wanted to become an entrepreneur
and i think i madly overestimated my
abilities and my first entrepreneurial
venture in finance was a complete
failure the bulk of which was entirely
my own fault
but it was a wonderful lesson and i was
able to pick myself up and the second
venture of mine which was the securities
trading companies went very well
subsequent to that i staged the takeover
of a large government-owned bank that i
realized after
buying the bank and that it was
effectively bankrupt this you this is
united bank of africa united bank out of
africa or united bank foreign i always
get it wrong myself so let's just leave
it at uda
okay united bank africa
[Music]
we'll return to hakeem's experience at
united bank for africa in just a moment
but first i wanted to hear hakeem's
perspective on nigeria as a whole
what are its opportunities for long-term
growth and what stands in the way
i am cautiously optimistic about the
growth prospects of nigeria i think that
the
fundamentals are as follows
a large population
and a population that i would say
is entrepreneurial
i hesitate to use the word as a matter
of culture but so i simply say has
historically
been entrepreneurial
and that has had a very deep sense
that
money is to be made it's not embarrassed
or ashamed of that has a sense of
initiative and does not feel dependent
on government
and therefore
that set of human resources
is a huge advantage for any country as
it intends to develop
it does have an oil base
which
even during a time of energy transition
i think is important
and therefore if properly used
gives you the capacity to
build and to fund an infrastructure
which is very important for the growth
of any country or economy
can i jump in right there so we all
heard the term dutch disease where the
dominant commodity
sector pulls resources which more
efficiently might be allocated to some
other activity than you know oil and gas
as petroleum becomes a less important
part of the overall gdp of nigeria
will we see kind of a reverse of the
resource curse and see more and more
investment flowing into other productive
sectors
or has that already happened
i don't think it's already happened i
think that the initial movement away
from oil
will be recessionary for nigeria
because i think that nigerians have
gotten very used to
the sense that there's a flaw
that a certain level of oil earnings
gives an economy and i think we're going
to have to we will struggle to adapt to
that but i do think that
as that situation persists
a certain determination a certain
resolution will kick in
as we now in a sense have our backs
against the wall
and now know that we have got to
intensify
our efforts to develop the economy
you mentioned this
large population an entrepreneurial
mindset in spirit i've also heard you
say in another interview that you're
kind of tired of the the demographic
dividend that people keep talking about
that having this very wide flat
demographic pyramid is
yes it could be an asset but it could
also be a liability could you say a bit
more about that yes the thing is that
all of the arguments for why a country
can be successful
are the same arguments
as to why a country can be unsuccessful
so for example a large market
can simply be 100 million people who
have very little income
very little spending power
it can simply mean that you have a
problem of overpopulation
you can't educate all the the people
concerned
on the one hand on the other hand
it can also mean that you have a
wonderful market
within which to test the products to
perfect the products and then to form
the basis of going into exports so you
couldn't go either way now
what i think is going to determine which
way nigeria goes is really going to be
the quality of leadership
and it's going to be the quality of
leadership
not only at the business level but
almost i would say in some respects more
important at the political level
because i think that the political level
determines the framework which allows
business leadership either to excel or
it constrains business leadership and
just to make an international comparison
if you just look at two countries in the
early 60s and i'll use the middle east
as an example you look at the united
arab emirates and then you look at libya
both had one two and a half million
barrels a day of oil
both had populations that were not
largely educated in the early 60s
in many respects libya was ahead because
it was in the mediterranean
and you'd have thought that its
proximity to europe assisted it greatly
but now now when you look at it 50 years
later
why has abu dhabi why has dubai taken
off
from desert towns that nobody thought
were going to be catapulted to where
they are right now and where is libya
right now that really came down to the
quality of leadership
so let's talk about that so good
governance is a precondition
for broad-based
robust persistent economic growth let's
put it that way
so what is the impetus because we all
know why there's bad governance because
there are certain interests that are
being protected and in a lot of
economies i've worked in many many
countries in my life it's usually that
very powerful vested legacy interests
are doing everything they can to
maintain their place and to prevent new
entrants to prevent competition and they
do that through all sorts of import
duties export licenses quotas
regulation that's designed to reduce
competition
where will the impetus for good
governance come will it come from
countries realizing that they're all
competing for the same
human and
capital investment capital and that the
winners will be the ones that create a
more
stable reliable predictable playing
field i think it's going to come in two
ways
on the one hand
the crisis
or the difficulties the countries
endure
in many respects triggers of a certain
introspection
and i'll just say that if you look at
countries like japan the crisis of the
second world war you look at what
happened to europe and you can see the
way in which
it ushered in years of enormous growth
in the 1950s and the early 60s so i
think crisis forces people
and forces nations to think again
and to rethink their model so i think
that that's going to be one impetus and
therefore i think that paradoxically the
covet situation the energy transition is
going to lead to a certain amount of
rethinking that's one aspect
the second thing which i'd like to point
out which is usually not often pointed
out
it comes from what you said about vested
interests
i'd like to take a slightly different
angle on what you've said i think that
there will always be vested interests
and there will always be powerful groups
who take care of themselves and i'm not
so sure that's the crucial question
i think the crucial question is
that elite
that is taking care of themselves
what is their long-term vision
for themselves
and for their countries
do they have a long-term vision in which
they still want to be on top
but they have the sense that they have
got to do enough for the base
of the population
to remain there and do they have a
picture of themselves as being the
leaders
of great countries
and you can characterize several
countries who are very much like that
all right or
is their vision
very extractive
they don't really care what happens to
everybody else they have three passports
their money is in a bank somewhere else
absolutely and so they deep down they
don't really care all right and they
don't have a sense of
patriotism and i see it very much in for
example i'll go back to the middle east
and i say very much that however well to
do i see some of the leading families in
the middle east it's still important
that emirates does very well
[Music]
hakeem has plenty of experience with
extractive elites from the six years he
ran the united bank for africa
this time at uba gave him a deeper
understanding of these systemic
challenges that face african finance
even now
now i understand it that when you when
you took the government's shares
what you inherited was a bank with far
too many employees
a high portfolio of non-performing loans
and it was not very well managed that's
a highly politicized so
what business does a guy who never ran a
bank have jumping into that
interesting that you asked that question
there's a japanese saying that sometimes
you have to jump through a window
not knowing what's outside
and the knowledge
of exactly what the problems are is
itself a constraint
and therefore i think that if i had
known too much
about banking i may not have done it i
may have said this is just too much
but in that sense i wasn't a
professional banker
i was just an mba who just had a certain
overconfidence
that mbas have that any problem can be
analyzed
can be assessed as a problem of
management a strategy
can emanate from it and you should be
able to execute and that was my going-in
approach to the matter
hakeem's story isn't just about the
problems he faced it's about how he
solved them
you've got to start shifting
who the customer base
how are the procedures improved upon
how do people get into the culture of
marketing
when they've really been accustomed to
people coming in
to see them as the banker they don't see
the banking as a service industry
in a sense it's uh a lot of it has to be
to do with the prestige of people coming
to you to borrow money
so i love this point so
i want you to share with me a moment
a critical inflection point
where you needed the bank's leadership
and staff
to adopt your cultural mindset about
what this bank should be is this a
matter of very slow incremental change
was there an all hands meeting in the
conference hall where you said folks
this is who we are going to be no i
think there was never one there were
several but the one that always hits me
the most
is the time at which
i kind of laid out our situation our
financial situation
and why we're going to have to do
certain kinds of things
i did it on a thursday or friday and on
monday
the
workers and some of the management had
taken over the head office building and
locked us out that was a pivotal moment
for me
because they knew head cuts were coming
no the new cuts were coming and they
genuinely thought that i was absolutely
talking nonsense
okay or in some cases they just could
not take change human beings don't like
change
and maybe if i was one of them i would
have reacted the same that was a pivotal
moment for me and it was then to just
finally go and sit down and talk to a
whole lot of them very hostile
environment
mr bella why do you hate
people so much why are you so
mean why are you so vicious why do you
like sacking people just because you're
privileged
and
explaining that the path we are taking
is going to lead us
to the complete collapse of the bank and
they say no it's never going to happen
climate change you know never going to
happen and you're trying to break it
down to them and say this is where we're
going to go
all right
i will go the way you're going
but these are the signs that you're
going to see
and
as you see those signs
let's reconsider
all right and so i think that one was a
pivotal moment for me because my fear
was
i need to carry them along but will they
realize it so late that we've gone over
the edge
so that's fascinating so it was your
sense that some
meaningful proportion of the bank's
employees had no idea about its
financial troubles or didn't fully
understand they didn't fully understand
did that include managers senior oh yeah
managers in particular did not
understand they did not the cash
position of this bank they didn't
understand where it was inevitably going
to lead because previous to that a lot
of the accounts had been falsified so
they were just declaring these profits
but effectively they were eroding
their capital
and a lot of them were not aware of it
so a lot of them for example didn't
realize that look we are banking
old customers
who are going nowhere there's a whole
new group of customers that we're not
banking who are going to be the future
and we need to start banking them
managing a sometimes hostile workforce
taught hakeem about the empathy required
to be an effective leader
so you needed to help them understand
that this was a crisis yes and then you
needed to help them have a vision yes of
a way out yes correct and you committed
to metrics along the way so that people
could see what was actually happening
yes now there's another point though
i also needed to understand
[Music]
why
they hated me
all right i didn't understand it until
that event until this lady i remember
she came up to me and just she just said
to me no mr pelosi i'm going to give you
a chance because
you said something of the speech you you
said that um
you don't like firing people and you
told the story about how you read
a story to your daughter before she went
to bed at night because your daughter
asks you dad people in school keep
saying that your dad
likes retrenching people what does
retrench mean
so the lady looks at me and said you
know
the fact that you could actually read to
your daughter
at night means that you can't be
completely evil that's exactly what she
used okay and i think that it suddenly
struck me that i had to also think about
how i was appearing to them
and then i had to realize that a lot of
my the people who came in to change the
bank
were people
like me
and therefore there were not many people
who were like
the people who were trying to change
all right and therefore there was a
cultural conflict as well and i needed
to now start bringing
other kinds of people to work with me
who were closer to the people i was
trying to change all right
because they could better sell what we
were trying to do
so for example if you're running a
company in which they're all high school
educated folks and that's how banks were
in those days
and you're arriving with a group of
trendy investment banking types all mbas
you're obviously setting yourself
but i didn't see that at the time
but that was a critical event in which
i saw i needed to change them
and i saw how i needed to change myself
[Music]
you've been involved as an investor as a
mentor or somehow potentially involved
in some of the biggest tech startups on
the continent
and i was going to ask you
there seems to be a lot of frothy
excitement about health tech ed tech med
tech fintech
and a lot of new capital flowing into
these sectors
does the market justify this level of
excitement and energy or is there enough
for everyone to grow in just the
nigerian market we'll go to the
continent in a second all right the
first thing i'll say to you is that
there's really nothing unusual
about the excitement there was
excitement about the banking industry in
nigeria at one time and we had 100 banks
at one time there was an excitement at
one point about the oil and gas industry
and we had about a hundred groups who
are all setting up their mickey mouse
oil companies
and in a sense that is probably in my
view a good thing
because what it does mean is that rather
than a government agency all right
only allow
three or four
powerfully connected groups
to dominate an area
you have a huge amount of competition
and then inevitably
there's going to be a shakeout
some are going to survive and be very
strong and very profitable and
many others
will just go by the wayside
now in the early years
everybody will be doing well but
inevitably what then happens is that
some can no longer
continue
to lose the money that they are losing
and the special breaks are no longer
there and they will fall by the wayside
and i've seen it the oil and gas
industry we saw it in banking in nigeria
and we're going to see the same thing in
tech and out of this i think a couple
of very strong groups
will emerge which have a combination of
the basic model is very good it's a good
model
the second element of it is that they
have cut to make that adaptation from
brilliant idea
to effective management
that successfully scales
and handles that transition and not all
groups can do that
and then at the same time it's also got
to maintain
a good relationship and understanding of
the
national regulatory environment
which in a sense
forms the basis of competition
[Music]
that national regulatory environment may
be the biggest key to whether these tech
startups particularly in finance can
succeed
i think that the fintech companies are
going to
they will go much farther than people
expect
and that the only thing i think that
will restrain them
is going to be
regulation it's a regulatory environment
that
thinks
banks
and sees the protection of the existing
as number one i've heard you say in a
previous interview that a lot of for a
lot of businesses how you manage the
government is 50 to 60 of your work in a
place like nigeria
what does that mean
that means that because the government
is such a critical market player
in the sense that it's either
buying services
where it is not a buying services it is
providing services on which you depend
it is writing the rules of the game all
right
and it has such an overwhelming power
within a judicial system
in which yes you can enforce your rights
but the time taken to enforce your
rights you may no longer exist as a
company
now
if that mindset is accompanied
by mindset on the part of the
bureaucrats or the political officials
that we have the right to exercise this
power
then you find yourself having to
work
having to deal with that entity all
right the government now a lot of young
people
of course have grown up in an
environment in which government was a
bad thing
the less government the better
government their children of the
reaganite and the thatcherite generation
now my generation is in that sense
different we're from the
lb johnson the kennedy and russia it was
a good thing what it does mean
is that they've got to move away
from thinking of the government as a
hostile group but a government
is some identity in which you've got to
explain to them what you're doing
they've got to understand the technology
they've got to understand the ecosystem
and many of them
simply don't understand it and when
government officials don't understand
something the instinctive action is to
say no right it's so much easier to say
no it's much less risk
i'm absolutely stunned at the number of
startups in this space and all the sort
of neo-banks and non-banks and all the
things that they're providing now i'm
going to stipulate that there is a role
for regulation to protect consumers
absolutely put yourself in the shoes of
the nigerian regulator i think it's
ntida i don't know which agency it is
but
what are they doing
to stay
current and to create a regulatory
environment that serves the function of
regulation without strangling the market
what i think they need to do more of
and i won't say that they're against
the tech companies
because i've experienced this kind of
situation when we first started a
securities trading company we had to
spend a lot of time talking to the
banking supervision to say we're not a
bank we're not taking deposits not
taking deposits and then to start
encouraging them
why don't you go visit other countries
that are say five years ahead of nigeria
so you can get a sense of what the
future is like
and then you can then talk to other
regulators
who've experienced this
and who have seen that it's not as
frightening
as you think it is
and then the next thing is that you've
got to let the regulators know in a way
that is not condescending
okay that they need to understand the
issues and they've got to hire into the
central bank a lot of people who are
younger than they are who understand
that i believe the participants in the
marketplace have to share with them look
there's some funny things that are going
on okay and we admit it
all right and these are the steps we
will take to ensure
that it won't happen again
so therefore there's a certain amount of
self-regulation that needs to take place
and sometimes you've also got to call
yourself out
because that builds a certain trust with
the regulator so he doesn't see it as us
and them
what about if the real
force behind the regulation is not
visible
that there are very powerful entrenched
interests actually turning the dials
and i can think of examples where in
peso tried to move for example into
south africa and the banks saw this
coming from a mile away yes and said no
way are these guys eating absolutely
we'll do what they're doing when we're
ready yes this is high risk trust us
we'll be there eventually how much of
that sort of
yeah the wizard of oz behind the
curtains going on yeah okay yes now
where
the incumbent waves the national flag
they are their strongest
so the impesar one into south africa
to me is expected the existing banks
will wave the national flag wrap rapid
round we're protecting our nation
against these foreigners with these
bizarre ideas now what would be
interesting is how they react to
a south african impessa all right
or a group of younger techies inspired
by an impessa
maybe even funded by an impessa
and then poses the question or says look
you the large incumbents
who grew up in the apartheid regime
what have you done
for lending
for the
poor
folks how have you been inclusive
and we think we are taking a shot at
that
and why should we
be regulated
out of that competition now that to me
would be the interesting
challenge and that to me is something
that may happen so i think that even
within cars like nigeria i think the
biggest issue
that a lot of the public has about big
banks is that it hasn't in a sense
benefited the wider population
in the way in which
telecoms
has so with the telecoms companies
it started off only the world to do
headphones
right but today the poor have phones
and pricing
has steadily dropped
now we haven't had that
same inclusive
aspect
to banking
[Music]
given akim's vantage point on african
finance i wanted his opinion on some of
the questions that we explored on season
one of grit and growth about fintech and
about the future of debt for small
businesses
what will it take
to
make credit
affordable to smes that 100 000 capex
loan in in the african continent because
if i if i have to say we have a thousand
alumni from our program and these are
typically i mean about 30 of them are
tech or tech enabled but most of them
are not on some kind of hockey stick
growth trajectory
or if equity was available to them
they're actually not interested in
giving up ownership of their company
what they want is
reasonable
affordable credit to grow and build
their business
and i don't care what country you're in
with a few exceptions the complaint is
that it's just not there banks are just
not interested in that business let's
look at it from the point of view as to
why don't the banks want to go into that
area
i think that it comes down to the
following issues one is
there's got to be enough data that can
predict who repays and who doesn't repay
so i think that the question of what
data is predictive
and how can you accumulate it i think
that's one in a very big important
aspect
then i think the second important aspect
is
what is the technology
that can allow us
to access these customers and utilize
this predictive data
in a manner that drops the cost of doing
so
because ultimately if the cost of
acquiring a customer
going through the transaction
and making
enough successful repayments
that cost has to be less
than the revenue generated from giving
the loan
and i think ultimately i think that's a
question of technology
data and how it is done and i think that
as you begin to crack that question
that problem you will then begin to make
progress there but i don't think that
can be done in the traditional
manner in which we have sought to do it
till now
although hakeem sees entrepreneurs
bringing real progress
he also preaches patience the thing i
want to
point out
is that as always
in a lot of new ideas you will always
have those companies who
they have the basic idea
and they can speak to it
and then you've got another set which is
usually a subset who approach this thing
with intense and unrelenting rigor you
mean on execution yes in operation yes
and there's always sometimes in some
companies a desire to move very quickly
because you have this sense that you've
got to move quickly before your
competitors
and there's money flowing in
investing in you and there's the danger
that you then launch
and you then grow before you have all of
these issues totally figured out
is that pressure coming from the
investors or from the founders
in some cases the investors and i think
that part of that is due to the fact
that
we still have and i would call it a u.s
imposed three to five year cycle in
investments
okay and i say u.s imposed not because
the u.s government directed it but
because
the timing in the united states for a
lot of these things is three to five
years and then you strategic exit or
something exactly you get your money
back out exactly now in my own
experience
as an entrepreneur
three to five years
i was still turning around
i realized that i needed to pivot a
little bit here
i realized that i got some highs wrong
okay
and i found it was really somewhere
between years five and seven
all right
or six seven eight that i now felt i was
in my stride
and then you started to get the truly
phenomenal or exponential growth and it
was it had a solid base all right so i
do think that we need a longer time
horizon so there's got to be more
patients in the capital and also the
founders themselves
needs to
acknowledge
that they've got to do very diligent
work
before
they roll things out
on the one hand we've got that vision
and i hate to use that word but you know
what i mean
but you've got to reduce
that to the series of steps that you
need to move from where you are
to where hopefully you want to go to and
if i have a worry is that i know a lot
of young folks who they've got that big
picture
but that the boring bit
of this step and this step and this step
which is often mundane
tiring and exhausting
that is is crucial
and as a founder you have to be more
than just diligent you've got to be able
to trust yourself and your process
courage is vital in whatever you're
doing
you're really leading people down a path
in which you pretend you can see the end
of the tunnel
as a leader but you can't really but you
have a
sense that this is roughly where you
need to go i often quote mcnamara we
talked about the fog of war and i deeply
believe that there is also a fog
in business
there is so much that you don't know and
i think great leaders have the ability
to live with
not knowing all the answers
but being able to carry people along and
solve those issues
as they come along and having the
flexibility
to make those changes and having the
sense of security of saying to
themselves
don't know everything
but i'll solve it as it comes along
the founder has got to have an
appreciation
of the complete
array of talents
that he or she needs
and of bringing them together
there will be some folks who are
particularly good at solving the
technical problem the one or two folks
who their forte is operations
and just executing they're one or two
folks who are going to be very good at
the fundraising element of it
constantly thinking about the cash flow
analysis
warning that the spend
is very high and don't think you have as
much runway as you think you have
all right and so i think that all of
these talents
really have to come together and i think
a founder has to appreciate
that
it's only a genius that is good on in
everything that's why i think the
business history
which
all founders worldwide study has to
let them know
that yes there was bill gates
yes there was steve jobs
but without a doubt there were two or
three other people who worked with bill
gates who you don't hear as much about
but who are indispensable
to the overall success and the same with
steve jobs
but the way it is one person gets a
disproportionate
share of the limelight and therefore it
creates a misleading sense of why you're
successful
i love the mindset point because so many
founders in the early days have to are
being called on to solve problems that
are way outside their comfort zone and
they have to do it yes but they also
have to understand that a certain point
that's going to slow the company down
right we call it post-heroic leadership
where you don't have to be the hero of
every story right and yes for technical
challenges for which there is a solution
you just maybe have to spend some money
to find it yes
that type of leadership can work but for
what we call in the stanford program
adaptive challenges
challenges to your strategy
competitive landscape
exogenous shocks
that they're without a team you're lost
and if the team thinks that you're going
to have all the answers they're not
going to come up with any absolutely
absolutely and i think it also
introduces and confronts this issue of
trust
trust in the sense that here you are
you're in a country in which
there are different ethnic groups
different religious groups
and you're going to have to work with
people often that you don't know
in a society in which
the site which is not heavily structured
there is not as much rule of law
elsewhere and therefore the need to work
with people that you trust becomes
essential and oftentimes
the problem of the founder
is that he has difficulty in
trusting other people because he said so
many stories about how a trusted b and b
took off with the company
hakeem's views on leadership reflect his
broader views about the individual and
the collective and what truly makes a
business successful
you were a guest keynote speaker at the
stanford africa business forum earlier
this year and you made a comment that
business leaders in africa are overrated
yeah
i really think that
i think for two reasons and one it's
because does kind of businessman in
africa
really
have as his ultimate objective
only the maximization of shareholder
value
we have the debate in in the united
states all the time part of me thinks in
the united states it's an easier it's a
slightly easier question simply because
this is already a very wealthy society
now in africa the imbalance of power the
skewed nature of power is even worse
so to me
one of the things that worries me a lot
is that we've spoken a lot about how
business should be in the forefront
the government should leave and hand it
over but we still haven't found
how for example
the private sector which is supposed to
be heroic how does it deliver
low-cost medicine
to 80 of the population
how does it deliver
can it deliver
infrastructure that goes outside of the
capital city and of one or two other
commercial centers
how does it develop
low-cost education health for everybody
we haven't
but i think you've answered the question
you didn't want me to ask also which is
that it's not that you have to abandon
the maximization of shareholder value
it's that your success should matter to
someone other than you yes that's when
we try to when we try to pick companies
for the seed program yes you know of
course we like social enterprises that
are commercially viable
but the question i always ask is if this
company grows 10x will it matter to
anyone other than the owners yes
are they solving a problem that i care
about that people there care about that
are they solving a meaningful and
important problem but that problem is
even more acute in africa and therefore
more and more and more we have to
measure how well we're doing not by how
many people on the forbes cover
not by how many billionaires africa has
but basically
what has happened
to the bottom 40 percent
are we able to say as the chinese can
say with many things we may not like
don't like about their political system
but they can say
we over the last 40 years have lifted
x hundred million
out of poverty
and i think that
business strategy business success has
got to be a strategy that yes enables
great companies
allows people to make certain effective
and enterprising people to make
good sums of money but it is also
got to be a system that lifts out of
poverty large proportions of the overall
population
i think this is the most compelling part
of hakeem's outlook that success on both
the micro and macro level is never about
just one person it's about everybody
it's reflected in how he leads his views
on regulators and his hopes for the
future of the continent
it's a vision that we at stanford seed
share and it's why he's such a good fit
for us
i'd like to thank hakeem bella osagie
we're lucky to have him on the podcast
and as our board chair
hakeem's philosophy aligns so well with
what we're doing here at stanford seed
and we're excited to work with him to
make our programs even better
this has been britain growth with
stanford graduate school of business and
i'm your host darius teeter if you like
this episode leave us a review on your
podcast app it really helps us to share
the stories of these incredible
entrepreneurs with as many people as
possible
to learn how stanford graduate school of
business is partnering with
entrepreneurs throughout africa and
south asia
head over to the stanford seed website
at seed.stanford.edu
podcast
[Music]
you